[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen viel
Fußball gibt es gleich von Norbert
Lehmann schönen guten Abend und wir
schauen was die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin und
Frankreichs Staatschef in China
erreichen wollen
Peking besuchen Zeichen des
ukraine-krieges die EU und Frankreich
hoffen dass Chinas Präsident hi Druck
auf Russland ausübt
Cyberangriffe auf deutsche Behörden
Hacker wahrscheinlich aus Russland legen
Webseiten von Ämtern und
Servicebetrieben Namen
und viel los auf Schienen und Straßen
der Osterreiseverkehr rollt an und in
Hamburg blockieren klimaaktivisten
Elbtunnel und Brücken
die Beziehungen zwischen China und der
Europäischen Union sind komplett so
nennt es eu-kommissionspräsidentin von
der Leyen sie ist gerade mit Frankreichs
Präsident macron zu Besuch bei Chinas
Staatschefin auf der einen Seite enge
wirtschaftliche Verpflichtungen auf der
anderen große politische Differenzen
gerade beim Umgang mit Russland seit dem
Angriff auf die Ukraine aus Peking
Miriam Steimer
Europa ist zu Gast in Peking an einem
Tisch dem für die perfekte Europaflagge
nur noch die Sterne fehlen es ist der
erste persönliche Empfang nachdem sie
sich drei Jahre lang nur auf
Bildschirmen gesehen haben
ihr Ziel unabhängiger von China zu
werden wiederholt
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
gleichzeitig liefert sie die Begründung
warum auch die heute abgeschlossenen
wirtschaftsstils in ihren Augen doch
alle irgendwie schon in Ordnung sind
wir müssen Risiken minimieren das
bedeutet uns auf die problematischen
Bereiche zu fokussieren während wir
anerkennen dass es eine Mehrheit an
Gütern Dienstleistungen und Geschäften
gibt die unproblematisch sind
für China zahlt sich aus auf diese neue
Strategie nur leise reagiert zu haben es
braucht Europa seinen größten
Handelspartner für seine angeschlagene
Wirtschaft
für macron zahlt sich aus dass er 50
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer
mitgebracht hat die Geschäfte laufen und
Europa hat auch noch eine Forderung
ich weiß dass ich auf sie zählen kann um
Russland zur Vernunft und alle
Beteiligten an den Verhandlungstisch zu
bringen
hier sagt zumindest teilweise das was
die Europäer gerne hören wollen
so besteht China darauf den Frieden
durch Gespräche und eine politische
Lösung zu fördern China ist bereit mit
Frankreich zusammen zu arbeiten
allerdings spricht er auch wieder von
den Sicherheitsinteressen aller Russland
inklusive das ist Chinas übliche Aussage
in der Neuauflage für Europa
da fragen wir nach bei unserer Peking
Miriam Steimer und unseren Brüssel
wird mit diesem Tag wohl zufrieden sein
und das aus drei Gründen erstens haben
chinesische und französische Firmen
heute lukrative Wirtschaftsdienst
geschlossen das hilft Chinas Wirtschaft
und das hilft seinem Image auf dem
Weltmarkt zweitens hat er seine gute
Beziehung zu Europa ins Schaufenster
gestellt das ist ihm wichtig denn er
möchte damit verhindern dass es einen zu
starken Schulterschluss zwischen Europa
und den USA gibt und in Sachen Ukraine
da hat er eine Waage Zusage gemacht mit
dem ukrainischen Präsidenten zu
telefonieren wenn Zeit und Bedingungen
passen ansonsten hat er sich als
Vermittler dargestellt und eine
Friedensbotschaft gesendet die ihnen
nichts weiter kostet denn zumindest
soweit wir bisher wissen gab es keine
konkreten Zusagen oder irgendetwas was
seinen Partner Putin zu sehr verärgern
würde solange China die roten Linien des
Westens nicht überschreitet scheint hier
mit seiner Strategie dem Spagat zwischen
Europa und Russland weiter gut zu fahren
dann kommen wir mal zur Brüsseler
Perspektive Ulf ein Hauptziel das
Besuchs war China dazu zu bewegen auf
Russland Einfluss zu nehmen um den Krieg
in der Ukraine zu beenden was wurde denn
dann da erreicht
macron und Ski haben schnelle und rasche
Friedensgespräche gefordert das soll ein
bisschen diesem Treffen ein
diplomatischen Glanz verleihen aber wenn
man in die Substanz geht ist doch fast
nichts erreicht und der Konflikt ist
eher schwierig man muss sehen dass das
Verhältnis gerade zwischen China und
Amerika sehr sehr schlecht ist und China
steht weiter eng an der Seite Russlands
es kauft weiter viele viele Rohstoffe
von Russland man sagt auch Russlands an
die Tankstelle von China und so hält
China russlandwirtschaftlich am Leben
und dann gibt es da noch die große Sorge
der Europäer und der Amerikaner das
schief vielleicht doch in wird Waffen
nach Russland liefern wird das ist diese
rote Linie von der Ursula von der Leyen
heute in Peking gewarnt hat davor hat
man Angst und wenn China diese Linie
überschreitet dann wäre wahrscheinlich
das Verhältnis mit Europa nachhaltig
beschädigt also wenn man ein Fazit von
diesem Besuch zieht muss man sagen von
Friedensgesprächen ist man nach wie vor
weit weg die Zeichen stehen eigentlich
eher auf Konflikt danke schön für diese
Einschätzung
Friedensgespräche für die Ukraine
vermittelt durch China davon hält
Russland nichts cremesprecher piaskov
sagte bisher gäbe es keine Aussichten
auf eine politische Lösung der Kreml
verteidigte auch die Stationierung von
russischen Atomwaffen im Nachbarland
Belarus das sah eine Reaktion auf die
ostarbeiterung der NATO Belarus und
Russland wollen auch künftig in
Sicherheitsfragen eng zusammenarbeiten
sagte Präsident Lukaschenko der gerade
zu Besuch in Moskau ist
die Gräuel des Krieges haben tiefe
Spuren hinterlassen bei den Menschen in
der Ukraine gerade Soldaten und
Soldatinnen erleben Tag für Tag wie
Menschen leben ihnen sterben oder schwer
verwundet werden sehen schreckliches
viele sind dadurch traumatisiert eine
Brühl hat in der Ukraine einen Ort
besucht an dem sie Hilfe bekommen
auch in der Reithalle ist der Tod nicht
weit weg
Schweigeminute für einen gefallenen
Kameraden in bachmut
die Soldaten hier sind auf Fronturlaub
Hunde Katzen Pferde das ist wirklich
eine sehr starke Hilfe eine emotionale
Unterstützung Entspannung alles hier
dient der Ablenkung
Katzen streicheln gegen das Trauma des
Kriegs reden müssen die Soldaten nicht
aber der Umgang vor allem mit Pferden
soll Ihnen helfen das alles zu
verarbeiten
mehr Glück mehr Positives Tiere
Kommunikation mit allen das führt zu
mehr Freude es wird heller in der Seele
und im Kopf
es gibt keine Zahlen über die Verletzten
die Toten die traumatisierten dieses
kriegs aber das Hilfe nötig ist sieht
auch die Armee und unterstützt das
Projekt das mit privaten Spenden
finanziert wird
wir verstehen dass dieses Problem
existiert was da auf uns zukommt auch
nach dem Ende des Kriegs deshalb
arbeiten wir schon jetzt daran
es ist verblüffend zu sehen wie die
Soldaten auf die Tiere reagieren sich
öffnen Freude zeigen
es geht hier nicht nur um die Pferde es
geht um die Stimmung das Team die Tiere
alles beeinflusst alles
für die meisten ist es nur eine kurze
Unterbrechung vom Krieg in zwei oder
drei Wochen sind sie wieder an der Front
und der Ukraine Krieg wird auch im Netz
geführt gerade sind auch deutsche
Behörden wieder das Ziel von
Cyber-Attacken geworden das sei grund
genug endlich aufzuwachen und in den
Schutz zu investieren sagt die
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
strafzimmermann die Gewerkschaft der
Polizei fordert ausreichend Geld um
notwendige IT-Fachleute zu gewinnen über
die Hecke Angriffe Fabian Köhler
die hannoverschen Verkehrsbetriebe
Angriffsziel von heckern die Webseite
Istra heute zum Teil nicht erreichbar
die buchungsfunktion für Tickets
eingeschränkt bereits seit Anfang der
Woche laufen in mehreren Bundesländern
offenbar koordinierte Cyber-Attacken
betroffen insbesondere verschiedene
Landesbehörden in Niedersachsen auch
viele Internetseiten der Polizei dieser
Angriff läuft auch weiterhin das nehmen
wir wahr bei uns hat er vor allen Dingen
öffentlich zugängliche Webseiten
beschädigt dass wir bisher wissen ist es
auf russische Hacker zurückzuführen und
das macht uns natürlich auch unruhig mit
sogenannten überlastungsangriffen legen
die Hacker derzeit den jeweiligen
Internetauftritt lahm greifen aber laut
Experten keine Daten ab es geht darum
erstmal eine gewisse Stärke zu
demonstrieren dass man eben im Prinzip
beliebige Ziele attackieren kann die
dann eben nicht mehr erreichbar sind
und natürlich auch so ein bisschen
Unsicherheit in der bevöl zu stiften
Russland als Drahtzieher in einem
anderen Fall hat vor wenigen Tagen ein
internationales Journalistenteam mit
zdf-beteiligung die vulkanpfalz enthüllt
demnach hat Russland mit Hilfe einer
privaten Firma Instrumente für groß
angelegtes Cyberangriffe entwickelt auch
zu einigen der aktuellen Attacken
bekennt sich eine pro-russische Gruppe
in chatverläufen des messenger-dienstes
telegram
das hat auch durch die angespannte
politische Lage in der Welt zugenommen
und weil es eben relativ geringe
technische Hürden gibt muss man damit
rechnen dass es auch weiterhin zum
Alltag gehört ob und welche
ausländischen Stellen wirklich hinter
den Angriffen stecken ist Gegenstand der
Ermittlung
es ist bereits der elfte Protesttag in
Frankreich haben erneut 10.000 Menschen
gegen die Rentenreform von Präsident
macron demonstriert in Paris Geräten
radikale Demonstranten und
Sicherheitskräfte aneinander
in Rennen im Nordwesten Frankreichs
wurden Straßenblockaden errichtet die
Demonstrierenden protestieren gegen die
schrittweise Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters von 62 auf 64
Jahre sie halten ihre Form für sozial
ungerecht gestern hatten die
Gewerkschaften ein schlichtungstreffen
mit der Regierung abgebrochen
kurz vor den osterfeiligkeiten wachsen
die Spannungen zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern die zweite Nacht in Folge
gab es Auseinandersetzungen auf dem
Tempelberg in Jerusalem Jugendliche
hatten sich nach israelischen Angaben in
der al-axam Moschee fabbarrikadiert und
mit Steinen und Feuerwerkskörpern
geworfen
daraufhin stürmte die israelische
Polizei das Gebäude
und am Nachmittag sind aus dem
benachbarten Libanon dutzende Raketen
auf den Norden Israels abgefeuert worden
mindestens drei Menschen wurden verletzt
Michael Beverungen in Tel Aviv wer
steckt denn hinter dem Beschuss aus dem
Libanon
laut israelischer Armee die radikal
islamische terorganisation Hamas das
würde auf einen neuen Organisationsgrad
der Hammers im südlichen Libanon
hindeuten und auf eine noch engere
Zusammenarbeit mit der Iran treuen
hasbollah die Hisbollah hat die
Verantwortung für den Beschuss abgelehnt
aber es ist klar dass es hier kein
Beschuss gibt ohne dass die hess Boller
dem zustimmt das gibt natürlich eine
weitere Eskalation jedenfalls ist das
genau die Strategie der Hamas eine
weitere Eskalation zu den bestehenden
Spannung herbeizuführen nur so kann sie
im Prinzip sich als Retter und
Verteidiger der Alexa Moschee und
Jerusalem profilieren wie Israel
reagieren wird ist noch offen in etwa 20
Minuten soll das Sicherheitskabinett
zusammentreten es trifft dieser Anschlag
Israel gerade in einer zumindest von
außen wahrgenommenen Schwächephase der
Verteidigungsminister eigentlich gerade
entlassen und noch nur provisorische im
Amt und die Frage ist wie das Kabinett
nun re agieren wird ob es quasi bewusst
Stärke zeigen will und mit Stärke
antworten will in diesem eskalierenden
Konflikt und die Frage heißt natürlich
auch was bedeutet das für den morgigen
Karfreitag wo zehntausende Pilger
christliche muslimische in Jerusalem
erwartet werden danke
im Fall des toten Mädchens im
bayerischen Wunsiedel geht die
Staatsanwaltschaft nun von einem
Tötungsdelikt aus es gebe derzeit aber
weder Beschuldigte noch Tatverdächtige
in der fränkischen Stadt nahe der Grenze
zu Tschechien hatte die zehnjährige in
einer Jugendhilfeeinrichtung gelebt am
Dienstag hatten Angestellte sie dort
leblos aufgefunden die
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt in alle
Richtungen
in Deutschland fehlen zehntausende
Wohnungen und die Baupreise für
Wohngebäude ziehen weiter an im Februar
waren sie laut Statistischen Bundesamt
15,1% höher als noch vor einem Jahr der
Grund gestiegene Materialkosten
Dachdeckerarbeiten sind besonders teuer
geworden sie kosten 17,1% mehr als
letztes Jahr
mehr als 400 Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter aus Politik Wissenschaft und
Gesellschaft haben einen Aufruf für mehr
Klimaschutz gestartet in einem offenen
Brief an Bundeskanzler Scholz schreiben
Sie Zitat jetzt zu handeln ist unsere
Pflicht was uns aktuell drohe sei der
globale Verlust unserer Kontrolle über
die Menschen gemacht der Klimakrise
unterzeichnet haben etwa Bürgermeister
aus ganz Deutschland klimaforscherinnen
und Vertreter verschiedener
Religionsgemeinschaften
Klimaschutz ist auch ihr Ziel die
Maßnahmen allerdings etwas radikaler
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generationen hatten
heute Hamburg im Visier konkret die
elbquerungen ein Transporter blockierte
eine Fahrspur im Elbtunnel davor hatten
sich protestierende auf die Fahrbahn
geklebt nach fünf Stunden konnte die
Polizei den Tunnel am Mittag wieder
freigeben im Beginn in Osterverkehr
bilden sich kilometerlange Staus
auch in anderen Regionen war in Sachen
Verkehr schon einiges los schließlich
sind Osterferien und die Feiertage
stehen unmittelbar bevor egal wie man
unterwegs ist mit Autobahn oder Flugzeug
gute Planung ist unbedingt
empfehlenswert Markus Mäuse gibt ein
Überblick
endlich geht es los Tom und Leo fliegen
gleich nach Fuerteventura Osterurlaub am
Strand Surfen im Atlantik die Freunde
können es kaum erwarten
ab in die Sonne 25 Grad da freuen wir
uns alle sehr drauf haben jetzt glaube
ich alle eine stressige Zeit hinter uns
und freuen uns jetzt dass es in die
Sonne geht jetzt kann ich endlich mal
ein bisschen durchatmen dem Alltag
Stress entkommen der Frankfurter
Flughafen rechnet mit bis zu 185.000
Reisenden am Tag bei 1100 Starts und
Landungen nach dem Chaos im vergangenen
Jahr wollen es die Flughäfen und
Airlines dieses Mal besser machen wir
haben mehrere hundert neue Menschen
eingestellt die hier am Flughafen
eingesetzt werden auch schon an Ostern
so dass wir glauben wir sind bestens
vorbereitet für den Ansturm ostern kann
kommen voll wird das auch auf den
Straßen der ADAC rechnet mit deutlich
mehr Verkehr als in den corona-jahren
die staureisten Tage heute und
Ostermontag unter anderem auf der A3 A5
A7 und A9 mit einem klimafreundlichen
Osterurlaub wird die Deutsche Bahn sie
rechnet mit einem fahrgastrekord voll
wird es vor allem im Fernverkehr die
Bahn rette deshalb wenn möglich flexibel
sein
wir haben auch auslastungsanzeigen in
unseren Systemen das heißt im Navigator
oder auch waren die kann nicht genau
sehen ist der Zug den nicht mehr
ausgesucht habe ist der richtig voll
dann empfehlen wir lieber Einzug später
oder ein Zug früher zu nehmen und
unbedingt vorher zu reservieren die Bahn
verspricht zu dem besseren Service von
heute an sollen zusätzliche Mitarbeiter
an den größeren Bahnhöfen helfen
und wir kommen zum DFB-Pokal Norbert
nach dem Bayern sind jetzt ja auch die
Dortmunder raus und das auch sowas von
verdient ein geradezu blamabler Auftritt
des BVB gestern Abend in Leipzig RB das
genaue Gegenteil taktisch spielerisch
und kämpferisch einfach top einen allen
Belangen souveräner 2:0 haben Sieg des
Titel Verteidigers vor allem der lange
verletzte Spanier Olmo belebt die
Leipziger Aktionen nur BVB Torwart Kobel
verhindert einen frühen Rückstand
überfällig der Führungstreffer RB
spaziert durch die Dortmunder Abwehr
Timo Werner das 1:08 22 Minuten vorbei
die Mini Negativ-Serie der Sachsen mit
drei Niederlagen ohne Erfolg Hummels am
Boden nach einem gesichtstraffer
Sinnbild der Dortmunder Leistung während
meine katastrophaler erste Halbzeit
gespielt in der zweiten Halbzeit wurde
es besser aber es wurde immer noch nicht
gut die einzige Chance der Westfalen in
der Nachspielzeit der eingewechselte bei
notens doch blaswich pariert ich bin
froh dass wir eine gute eine sehr gute
Reaktion gezeigt haben
und jetzt wissen wir wieder wie
Fußballspiele gewinnen geht gegen
aufgerückte Dortmund oder das 2:0 durch
Orban und dann darf Rose endlich seine
beachtlichen Sprintqualitäten zeigen
[Applaus]
ja und zuvor hatte Stuttgart den letzten
Zweitligisten aus dem Wettbewerb
geworfen der VfB gewann in Nürnberg
durch das Tor des Abends von so Mio in
der 83 Minute ja ein perfekter Einstand
für Stuttgarts neuen Trainer Sebastian
vier Vereine sind es jetzt also nur noch
im DFB-Pokal Frankfurt Freiburg
Stuttgart und Leipzig die Auslosung der
beiden Halbfinalpartien am Ostersonntag
gespielt wird dann am 2 und am 3 mai
Klatsche im Classico Real Madrid trat
gestern Abend im spanischen
Pokalwettbewerb Copa del Rey beim FC
Barcelona an ja und demütigte den Erz
Rivalen geradezu herausragend bei den
Königlichen Karin Benzema mit seinem
Patrick die Treffer in der 508 und hier
in der 80 Minute zum 14.0 entstand
Madrid steht da mit dem Finale und
trifft dort am 6 Mai auf Club Atletico
Osasuna
das Wassersport danke schön
Wetter heißt es Schauer Gewitter aber
auch Sonnenschein genau das gleich von
essentiali Christian Sievers begrüßt sie
um 21:45 Uhr zum heute journal schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter auf unserem
Vorschau Film sehen wir den Regen der
schon reingezogen ist nach Deutschland
und der verlagert sich in der Nacht und
bis morgen dann in den Süden ja und da
gibt es durchaus einige Schneeflocken an
den Alpen und auch im Tagesverlauf
Gewitter ja ansonsten zieht von Osten
her neuer Regen in die östlichen
Landesteile dazwischen gibt's viel
Sonnenschein das ist die Übersicht und
wir schauen in die Nacht da gibt es eben
Regen im Westen der verlagert sich
langsam nach Süden an den Alpen schneit
es etwas sonst klagt auf ihn in den
östlichen Landesteilen deutlich kälter
bei 0 bis -3 Grad und 7 Grad plus am
mildesten am Niederrhein morgen also im
Südwesten durchwachsen mit Regenschauern
und auch Gewittern sonst im Osten
ebenfalls Regen dazwischen viel Sonne
bei höchsten Temperaturen von 13 bis 14
Grad nach Nordwesten hin am kühlsten an
der Oder uns Neiße 6 bis sieben Grad und
am Samstag im Osten durchwachsen mit
Regen sonst aufgelockern locker damit
etwas Sonnenschein bei 7 bis 14 Grad
Ostersonntag dann wärmer und vor allem
Ostermontag auch trocken dazu damit ein
schöner Abend